der lieblingssport der deutschen ist gut
durch corona gekommen die saison wurde
zu ende gespielt die liga wirtschaftlich
gerettet die fans bekamen ablenkung in
harten zeiten und der frauenfußball
warum steht er trotz aller erfolge immer
noch im schatten der männlichen kicker
genau darüber werden wir sprechen erst
einmal müssen aber natürlich auch ganz
kurz thematisieren dass man ja wirklich
darum kämpft dass die bundesliga jetzt
ab september sitzung wahnsinn wenn das
system relevant werden soll wobei wir
noch nicht mal wissen wie es mit schulen
und kitas weiter geht also eher als ich
das gehört habe dass man das ich freue
mich ja für den fußball das ist ja auch
alles schön und gut aber also wenn kita
und schulen weiterhin geschlossen
bleiben oder teilweise geschlossen
bleiben wir aber bundesliga ganz normal
erleben dürfen dann bin ich raus
ja das ist totaler quatsch aber da
geht's einfach ums geld es geht ist
menge geld die dahintersteht es geht
auch nicht darum wir müssen den fans
unbedingt etwas geben das ist glaube ich
tatsächlich zweitrangig ich glaube es
geht darum er den ganzen fußball mit
arbeitsplätzen mit dem geld was dahinter
steht aufrecht zu erhalten
und deswegen ist er geht das ganz klar
erstmal über die kinder und das mich
schockiert dass auch aber steffi
wahrscheinlich dass angetragen wird
meine meinung genau was heißt profi also
meine meinung dazu ist jedes unternehmen
und dazu gehört eben auch die bundesliga
denn sie schaffen nun mal auch
arbeitsplätze die die möglichkeit haben
das wieder zu eröffnen und alles dafür
tun dass das im rahmen des möglichen
stattfindet dann finde ich das in
ordnung und auch wenn wir alle über den
fussball schimpfen sie haben alles
möglich gemacht dass das man auf das
medizinische auf den abstand und auf all
das wert legt und ich bin natürlich auch
enttäuscht dass kindergärten oder
schulen
aber hier ist es nicht angebracht
darüber zu diskutieren warum der große
fußball das kann sondern wie schaffen
wir es dass die schulen und alle anderen
auch der amateurfußball darf nicht
fußball spielen die
die sind gerade im training ja also ich
finde es schade dass wir das kritisieren
wo wir sagen das sind arbeitsplätze also
also ist es für dich systemrelevant wir
ja ich sage mir ich arbeite in der firma
die gerade unwahrscheinlich viele
schulden machen muss damit wir unsere
arbeitsplätze nicht verlieren und dann
bin ich doch vor drohungen wenn ich mit
der bundesliga möglichkeiten schaffe
dass die leute wieder arbeiten können
ich verstehe den punkt aber ich glaube
patricia mir geht es auch gar nicht
darum dass die nicht arbeiten dürfen
sondern es geht aber darum wenn man eine
lösung findet für die bundesliga dann
muss es doch möglich sein eine lösung
für schulen und für kita hier sind das
eine das andere nicht erheben kann
dieser auf jeden fall aber da ist ja
nicht die liga dran schuld und das bin
ich auch nicht
es ist auch nicht und ich sind auch
nicht dass die liga schließen muss damit
meine kinder in die schule wieder in den
finnen nur wenn es gelingt vor einem
bereich so ein perfektes konzept in
allen folgen dann sollte es ein in einem
anderen bereich der mir persönlich sehr
viel wichtiger auf jeden fall ebenso
schnell ein richtig gutes gelände
sollten wir dann die menschen die dieses
fußball konzept erstellt haben einfach
mal zur ins bildungsministerium
rüberschieben dass die vielleicht eine
lösung auch für schulen und kitas machen
das wird anscheinend sind die schnelle
art die hand ich glaube aber auch dass
es teilweise doch auch systemrelevant
sein kann weil wir ja nicht
unterschätzen dürfen wir habe gerade
über die spaltung der gesellschaft
gesprochen und es gibt ein großteil
dieser gesellschaft die ihre freude
erfährt wo das gemeinschaftsgefühl
gestärkt wird das große wir auch durch
solche spiele und wenn das auch mit
zufrieden mit zur genesung beiträgt als
auch zur seelischen sag ich jetzt mal
dann finde ich es auch nachvollziehbar
ja also ich glaube dass das gerade auch
kinder ja unwahrscheinlich gerne raus
wollen fußball spielen wollen und wenn
die liga das vorbildlich so auch umsetzt
wie sie sagen normal passend 80.000 raus
aber aufgrund der
regelungen sind dann halt nur 30.000
oder 40.000 im stadion und trotzdem
kommen die menschen mal raus aber alles
bitte mit sorgfalt und darauf sein wie
empfindest du letztendlich als ungerecht
dass quasi die bundesliga die profis die
dürfen spielen aber die muss genau eben
den sport das raus
sie dürfen es nicht dass stört mich auch
und das ist das was ich kritisiere wo
ich sage wir aus dem amateurfußball
würden auch gerne spielen haben jetzt
mit dem trainingsbetrieb begonnen und
dürfen aber unsere saison nicht zu ende
spielen und da gebe ich dir recht da
hätten die landesverbände auch gucken
können dass ihr das früher möglich
machen weil zuerst hätte ich die kinder
gesehen die daraus sollen
und woran liegt das ich denke mal das
ist bei 26.000 vereinen schwer ist die
medizinischen sicherheitsmaßnahmen
vorzubereiten wie in den schulen wie in
den kindergärten da hat man viel zu
lange gewartet sich wirklich darauf
vorzubereiten weil es war klar dass wir
irgendwann wieder öffnen wollen
und wenn man dann hört in den schulen
können wir nicht wir haben keine laptops
wir haben das nicht wir haben dies nicht
dann frage ich mich was hat man getan
während der zeit ja hoffentlich lernen
wir da mal dazu also dass wir wirklich
den wunsch das wäre
wir sehen dass es bei der bundesliga so
schnell geht das wir sagen so jetzt aber
gesehen was wir da brauchen jetzt nehmen
wir ein bisschen geld in die hand und
schaffen das bei den schulen und
kindergärten genauso soviel zum thema
männerfußball und so wird das
frauenfußball in deutschland behandelt
wir brauchen keine eier
wir haben pferdeschwänze wie bitte
[Applaus]
ganz schön frech aber auch irgendwie
ganz schön witzig so präsentiert sich
die deutsche frauen nationalmannschaft
ja ehrlich meinung ja ich fand den spot
alter dann raus kam der ist jetzt nicht
meins ich habe oder muss auch
ehrlicherweise sagen dass ich mir ich
habe lange dafür kämpfen müssen dass der
frauenfußball eigenständig ist dass wir
so wahrgenommen werden dass wir
sportliche leistungen bringen wir haben
große erfolge gefeiert und diesen
vergleich mit den männern
den will ich ja eigentlich loswerden und
jetzt kam dann dieses video dieser spot
der an sich witzig ist aber nicht meins
also hat quasi den frauenfußball noch
mal etwas zurück boykottiert das will
ich damit nicht mehr sagen die hatten
natürlich das ziel da noch mal so ein
bisschen auf sich aufmerksam zu machen
ich hätte halt einen anderen weg gewählt
weil ich glaube wir haben ganz tolle
typen wir haben spielerinnen die auch
ausstrahlung haben und die sich nicht
über den vergleich mit pferdeschwanz und
eiern darstellen müssen sondern sie
können das auf ihre authentische art
machen und mit mit ihrer leistung und
das hätte ich mir gewünscht aber den
vergleich wird man ja nie ganz los ich
habe gelesen irgendwie in der bundesliga
wenn frauen und spielen verdienen sie
39.000 brutto im jahr
männer verdienen in der dritten liga
120000 euro
ja und da frage ich mich also du wirst
natürlich sind das wirst du ja am besten
erzählen können man wird diesen
vergleichen die düssel ich mich auch
gefragt wohin nimmt man die motivation
da noch rein zu gehen und sagen ich
bisher weist also ich meine bei dem feld
da kann dann geht dann spiele ich jedes
wochenende mit meinen mädels aber die
strecke laufe ich für euch jetzt nicht
weisst du deine motivation hält genommen
zu sagen ich mache es trotzdem weil
fußball schon immer meine leidenschaft
war und neben dem dass ich persönlich so
viel mitgenommen habe durch den fußball
soziale kompetenz ich bin wenn ein
mischling ich wurde diskriminiert und
der fußball gibt einem so viel mit dass
man letztendlich aus einer großen
leidenschaft daneben
auch diesem sport nachgeht und ich habe
mich nie darum gekümmert ob die männer
mehr verdienen
ich habe erst als dfb angestellte
verstanden was alles dahinter steckt und
dass wir aufpassen müssen wenn wir
einfordern dass frauen genauso viel
verdienen sollen wie die männer
weil der die wirtschaftlichen
dimensionen im männerbereich sind
einfach ganz andere und mir wäre lieber
wenn man rausgeht und sagt der
frauenfußball steht heute hier
perspektivisch können wir da hin und wir
brauchen das und das und das und das
aber was braucht man weil ich frage mich
immer wo geht das interesse verloren
warum sind die so viel oder warum haben
sie zu viel mehr sponsoren etc
wieso verdienen die so viel mehr wo
unterscheidet sich das wenn du schon
alleine die bundes liegen nimmst bei den
männern hatte in dortmund 80.000 und im
frauenfußball bei einem top verein bei
dem bei dem champions league spiel fünf
bis sechstausend bei einem finale
möglicherweise auch 20 bis 30.000 dann
ist es aber von der uefa ausgerichtet
also da da hängen viel zu viele dinge
dran als oder es ist so komplex dass man
das jetzt nicht mit mit einer lösung
schafft sondern man man muss eben immer
auch gucken dass der frauenfußball da
nicht in die dimensionen von dem
männerfußball kommen kann was nicht
heißt dass wir nicht trotzdem auch es
schaffen können wir spielen tollen
stadien wir können zuschauer gewinnen
und wir können uns auch vermarkten
also das ist alles möglich nur bitte
nicht im vergleich zu den männern und es
ist ja auch als nicht nur so dass wir
das problem im fußball haben das ist ja
fast in allen jobs so dass frauen
weniger geld verdienen für dieselbe
leistung da können wir uns ja auch in
unseren sozusagen ressorts nicht von
fragen sprechen sage ich mal
und trotzdem finde ich natürlich
bedenklich ich habe eine schwester die
bundesligaspielerin war
und die hat trainiert wie ein profi
fünfmal die woche wurde bezahlt wie ein
amateur
das heißt man nebenbei noch zusätzlich
arbeiten muss damit man das finanziell
auch irgendwie hin bekommt das geht auch
wiederum auf die leistung also es ist ja
im grunde genommen eine spirale und
meine frage wäre ist das so ein
ungeschriebenes gesetz
auch diese trennung nach männern und
frauen oder ist das in unseren köpfen
beziehungsweise wenn du mal die
möglichkeit hätte ist welche
bundesligamannschaft würdest du gern mal
trainieren
welche bundesligamannschaft ich wünsche
mir einfach oder ich fordere eine frau
mal mit um den anfang zu machen in die
männer bundesliga
wir haben die schiedsrichterin mit der
bibiana steinhaus und da sollten auch
noch einige folgen und dann sage ich mir
ganz klar
kompetenz ist unisex also es sollte doch
keine rolle spielen ob ich mann oder
frau bin
jeder oder in den köpfen ist es
selbstverständlich dass jedermann eine
frauenmannschaft natürlich trainieren
kann
warum denn andersrum nicht als kann ich
überhaupt nicht verstehen und ich würde
heute alles darauf geben zu sagen eine
inka grings die sie schon bewiesen hat
könnte auf jeden fall einen männer
bundesliga vereine 10 a mannschaft
natürlich es ist mir dass es gibt genug
kompetente trainerin die das auch tun
könnten wenn die männerköpfe mal ein
bisschen offener werden und es zulassen
dass eine frau genauso diesen job machen
kann
jürgen klopp jedoch so jemand der das
bestimmt möglich machen könnte denkt
doch ein bisschen über die grenzen
hinaus
der ist mir ja ja ja der wäre auf jeden
fall offen doch ich finde du wärst super
dafür so was mal schöne auf und das ist
gerade so schön ein schönes schlusswort
gesagt wenn die männer endlich ihre
köpfe ein bisschen mehr aufmachen würden
ja das finde ich schön